so today's video I want to talk about a
subset of problems in maths called
orchard problems which are not really to
do with trees but it's kind of helpful
to think about trees so you can think of
apple trees or you can think about
forest fruit trees they're quite often
planted in deliberate plantation ways so
in lines have you ever seen if you're
driving down a road and there's a huge
vineyard you get this weird effect when
you see something that you see you look
down the video and you see just a line
of trees and then suddenly move a bit
and you see that this stretches on
forever and as you move you get this
light coming in and out of phase and
it's quite a nice effect actually
there's a lot of mass to ask about these
things like which trees can you see at
any one point at which trees can you not
see and can you see out when you walked
into other trees in the way and does it
matter where you stand and that's the
sort of thing that often gets described
as orchard problems and the one I want
to show you it's a simple one where
they're surprising the unexpected answer
imagine you're standing at the edge of
an infinite forest or orchard this is a
mathematical one so the trees are thin
and and all the trees are on coordinate
points so if you imagine a coordinate
grid that they call this lattice points
in the trade the points with integer
coordinates so 1 comma 1 1 comma 2 and
I'm just gonna put loads of trees on
this because this is gonna be where
we're gonna play for a while we're gonna
play in the orchard for a bit let's
start as in all good mathematical models
by keeping it simple and later on we can
upgrade that but so the simplest ways to
assume that they're mathematically thin
they're points which is obviously not
what real trees do but we'll ask
questions about that before we upgrade
the model to be more realistic well kind
of but if you look directly at it there
is a tree there and actually that's what
I'm when I start asking about which
trees can you see so I'm gonna imagine
that for the sake of the rest of this
argument we're gonna stand the origin
and I could have done all the trees
going over here and down here but we'll
just work with this quadrant and you can
extend it
in your own mind if you wish and the
real question is if all these trees are
out there and they carry on forever this
is an infinite forest so it doesn't end
in those directions there are a lot of
trees I'm gonna just put that out there
there's possibly some level of infinity
number of trees and I think you can see
some of them although your caveat is
noted that mathematically thin things
are gonna be harder to see than real
trees but if I for example if I stab
this point and I look directly
forty-five degrees into the forest I can
see that tree like if I get it right I
can see that tree obviously if it's thin
maybe as hard at sea but I also can't
see the trees behind it
they're directly in line so there are
some obvious questions which are not
interesting yet but about visibility and
so a lot of these problems are also
called visibility problems or latus
problems I likely err more poetic
orchard problems think there's the
question and I can ask you this Brady if
you're standing at this corner I'm gonna
claim you can see some trees for example
when you can see that tree if you look
in the right direction you can also see
that tree if you look along with that
direction and you would then hide that
tree and actually behind it so some
directions you look you can see trees
and I hope you agree with them is there
any direction Brady that you could look
standing here into the forest and not
see a tree eventually and I'm interested
in your intuition about this my
intuition is no because eventually if
you go far enough you do a hit one even
if you like carve out to miss the first
few than he goes upriver now I have the
same intuition about that and the answer
is not as simple as that the other
standard answers to this question are
you look up no trees up there which is
great it's hilarious but if you look
along the axes there are trees on there
as well so I think it's obvious I'm
gonna claim it obvious that you can see
some trees is it all trees or are there
gaps and where are the gaps if there
already and that's that's what we're
gonna play with because it's it's
surprisingly easy to answer so the first
thing I'd to point out is that I know
which tree I can see based on what angle
I look on the line actually the angle is
not so important as the gradient so if
you're standing here and you look along
an angle of 45 degrees there then you
will see this tree and that's got a
coordinate of 1 comma 1 now actually the
45 degrees is pretty intuitive but it's
also a gradient of 1 and just a mighty
what a gradient it's like how far along
you go for how far up you go for
everyone along rise over run is the
greedy this has got a gradient of 1 for
every one along you get one and this
line here I'm less worried about well
the angle as I could work it out but I
need some trigonometry but I can tell
you the gradient of that line the
gradient here equals 2 and it's hit the
tree at 1 comma 2 so I'm gonna claim
that if I know I'm gonna hit a tree it
can probably calculate the gradient of
the line I hit so if I picked this point
he is that gonna be good well that's 1 2
3 4 5 and 2 up so it's the point 5 comma
2 and actually I can work out which line
will hit it because it's got a go
there and it will carry on but because
I've got a lion I've got some distances
I can work out the gradient of this one
is the rise over the run which is gonna
be 2/5 well it's lovely is that I now
know which lines will hit which trees
and if I find a tree of hit I also know
the gradient of the line I'm now
wondering if your intuition has been
adjusted from when I first asked you
said you wouldn't hit you'd always hit
tree eventually right you're worried
that you wouldn't well if we can make a
gradient of that's not made of integers
hi-hi is one of those massively annoying
numbers it turns up everywhere you don't
expect but that's just one example of a
number now which would do what you've
just claimed to it it's not built of
integers or in ratios or integers and
this is where they get the word rational
because of that ratio of integers so
ratio naught would be better
pronunciation except no one uses that
look so these are all rational numbers
if I look along a rational gradient
I will hit a tree so if you looked along
a line of gradient you said pie
well pie is close to 3 so the gradient
is roughly 3 it would go
you just got Bobbitt so it's three point
one ish so you kind of head up there it
would be something like this line but it
would miss that tree anyway up here it's
not obvious to me where it would go next
or in fact whether it would here tree
unless I know something about pie which
you've kind of mentioned that it is
irrational it's not a ratio now if it
was a ratio it would hit a tree since
it's not a ratio
it can't here tree that's gonna just
miss the 22 over 7 tree it's gonna be
really close to it because these
ridiculously close to 22 up seven pie is
really well approximated by that
rational number and there's some other
really good ones too but it is gonna
miss because if it didn't miss it would
be a rational number now there are lots
of irrational numbers then pretty indeed
unintuitive things to exist but we can
prove they exist as James has done a
lovely video about root two that we
think that's the first one that anyone
realized ah no ratio and you can prove
it which means there are lines on this
diagram that you could look along and
you will never see a tree and that's the
first are sees like alright so there are
some lines you won't ever see a tree
despite the sports going on forever like
kind of like that first result is like
oh I can see less trees in fact
infinitely many trees but there are some
lines I can look and never see a tree so
the real question is
if you pick a direction of random are
you likely to see a tree or are you
gonna miss and this is where my mind
starts sort of complaining about things
because the answer is to do with how
many numbers there are how many trees
can you see well as the same question is
how many rational numbers are there
everyone says infinitely many it turns
out the mathematicians have this nice
way of talking about infinity of
different sorts so absolutely the
rational numbers have a size of infinity
which is we countable James grime
Enfocus about a coffin to cause them
list of all which is a nice way to think
about it you can't actually count them
because gonna finish but you can list
them in a way that means you've captured
them all so we really have to ask how
many irrational numbers are there
because if there's more maybe we're more
likely to miss a tree which is then we
could ask questions about can you count
the Irrational's and again if you go and
look into the study of infinity look up
and work by Georg Cantor or a nice video
by James grime on an amazing mass
youtube channel he explains to you why
the irrational numbers are uncountable
or unlist of all which means there are
infinitely many more irrational numbers
than rational numbers which means if you
pick a direction at random in this
forest you probably miss all the trees
in fact not even probably probability 0
the Yule hare tree you are 100% gonna
always miss the trees which means if you
stand on the corner mathematically you
can't see any trees because every
direction
look there are no trees except you can't
see some because we've picked out some
but there would be infinitely many more
that you can never see or lines which
should never hit a tree so these trees
are sort of super super-thin
with a point thing yeah and I'm standing
in the middle of the forest I'm gonna be
reined with light yeah it's all gaps and
this is completely irrational to sort of
have a horrifying pun these irrational
numbers they're so densely populated
compared to the rationals that
everywhere you look you're lucky to hit
them and not these special rationals
which are really rare in comparison in
fact so rare that they account for 0% of
all the numbers but it still messes with
my head being standard in a forest of
infinite trees and not see any of them
which is where the mathematical model
comes into question like ok because
they're infinitely thin you could stay
upgrade than the model you could say
well what if the trees are a little bit
thick or maybe if you if you think about
this is firing a laser beam and the
order
then you could say what if my laser beam
is a little bit thick and it's very easy
to start realizing that eventually when
the thickness comes in you do get trees
blocking away and you're going to forest
or you see is trees which is different
from what we just explained but the
question is how far can you see into the
forest and there something we've got
quite a real-life question of like what
how far does this lay they actually get
before it gets blocked by tree or depend
on the thickness that depend on maybe
the size of the orchard and so those
questions become orchard problems and
the the famous one is Polly's orchard
problem if you want to look it up it's
to do with how far can you see or could
you get out with the wood with your
laser depending on the size of the
orchard and it's saying that if the
trees are one millimeter thick suddenly
you would have zero gaps on an infant's
gap on an infinite scale you are
completely correct that mathematically
thin is the only reason you can see
nothing and as soon as there's anything
less so you can't get out at all but
there are some other interesting
thoughts is like on the infinite one
with the mathematical thing trees you
could ask instead about the lines in
this forest you could ask about the
points so which points can you see which
trees are visible in this first the ones
all behind the one one are invisible if
you're standing in the corner they're
doomed to be never be seen by any line
because there's locked by this one but
that point is visible but that one's not
so which points are and maybe if you
picked a point at random out of all of
them what are the chances you've picked
a visible tree talking about picking
random stuff from infinitely many things
is dangerous mathematically actually
what we're talking about is if you make
it finite like N and N and then answer
that question when it's finite and then
let M head off to infinity it turns out
you still have a sensible answer the the
chance I'm gonna tell you this the
chance of a visible tree if you pick one
at random and this blows my tiny mind is
six over PI squared another instance of
pi turning up the place you least
expected but this is because of
something called the Riemann zeta
function which I think there are other
videos available about and it's because
of the fact that if you actually want a
visible tree what you need is the trees
picked to have two numbers the
coordinates here which are co-prime
because if they weren't co-prime if they
had common factors they'd be hidden by
an earlier tree so what we're asking is
like the chance of picking a visible
tree is actually then abstract
mathematical question pick two numbers
at random order chance they're co-prime
the answer is the Riemann seeds function
with s equals to look it up and it turns
out to be interesting it's not obvious
why that's the case but the Riemann zeta
function is a treasure trove of
non-obvious mathematical stories so if I
was allergic to apple trees and I wanted
to walk out of this forest without going
near one what is the best lines we'll
walk along I'm gonna disappoint you
first of all you're gonna go near one
but maybe there's a line which is least
near it's still gonna be near I'm gonna
fail and maybe you could argue
mathematically you gonna get pretty
pound close but anyway the idea that
there may be a line which there's least
near means there's a most irrational
number and actually it is this line the
reason is I'm not gonna go into now but
there are some interesting familiarities
about so here's my little computer
screen of some some trees this line is
at a gradient of precisely one plus the
square root of 5 all over 2 which if
it's not familiar to you you've probably
heard it by different name is called the
golden ratio it's roughly 1.618
obviously if I told you the full decimal
will be here for longer than you want to
watch video this golden ratio times up
in lots of places and it is the line
that dodges the most trees it's not easy
to show in this case but in fact
infinitely many but this one seems to do
furthest away because we know something
about the golden ratio which is that
it's the least well approximated by a
rational number which means in this case
it's the line that's least near any tree
and one thing you can see nicely about
this is if you imagine this line in the
middle is the the golden ratio gradient
and you imagine it was an elastic band
going off of infinity and you pulled
this end along it would catch on these
trees and if you pulled it up it would
catch on some other trees and it turns
out that these numbers are familiar this
is the coordinate one one this isn't the
coordinate one two this is the
coordinate two three the next one it
hits is three five those numbers I'm
reeling off are all from the Bonacci
sequence in fact all the treaties that
they said last aground catches on are
the numbers from the Fibonacci sequence
and that's another reason why the
Fibonacci sequence captures in its
ratios the golden ratio as a very
intriguing number which we should
explore I think a bit more in another
video well orchards might cause some
problems but one thing that shouldn't
cause the problem is designing a website
not if you use Squarespace this is a
service I use every day
various blogs podcasts ecommerce and if
you want to do anything online you
should be checking them out too they've
got superb templates that makes
designing your site easy although you
can't tweak it to get it how you want it
any site you design automatically scales
perfectly on a computer or a tablet or a
phone you don't have to think about that
stuff they've also got brilliant
customer support the best thing to do is
just go and have a look go and have a
play and see how easy it is go to
squarespace.com slash numberphile and if
you do that you'll get 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain
that's squarespace.com slash numberphile
our thanks to them for supporting this
episode